[Music]
earthquakes are something that people
think about in Southern California all
the time that's in the back of our minds
and you have said in your opinion your
expert opinion we are a hundred and
fifty years overdue for a big earthquake
in Southern California is that true
right
just the San Andreas Fault San Andreas
Fault okay and that is the biggest
threat and you say we're a hundred fifty
years overdue how bad is it going to be
when the big one comes um it's gonna be
three minutes of shaking during the
event it was seven seconds of Northridge
for people who remember that and
afterwards will have lost all of the
aqueducts coming into Southern
California will have broken enough pipes
in the ground it's going to take six
months to get water back into all our
houses we'll lose electricity 1800 dead
but 300,000 buildings badly damaged okay
so good to have you here mr. joy no I'm
actually think that the more we
understand that the better off we'll be
so what are the biggest misconceptions
about earthquakes in your opinion what
are the things that people think that
are just plain wrong that they're gonna
die most people are afraid of dying in
an earthquake you are far more likely to
be murdered in Los Angeles
[Applause]
makes the murder rate some bad it's
actually showing how few people die in
there
okay good good I am getting at it you
were trying to get us to highly highly
unlikely to die in an earthquake
especially if you follow simple rules is
that right that's right we say drop
cover hold on which means get to the
ground before the earthquake throws you
there mm-hmm
get under a table if it's nearby so the
rest of us are sort of and guess what if
these two try to get over to my table I
am shoving them away anyway because the
earth is moving so much the biggest
injury we see is sprained ankles and
broken legs from people trying to run
during the earthquake and it throws them
to the ground that and glass in the feet
because people run through the broken
glass so what you're saying is has
always been my instinct that I remember
I lived here back in the 80s when I was
getting started in show business
yeah 1880s and I lived here back in the
80s and there were a lot of earthquakes
and remember I always stood in a doorway
because I was told to do that you say
that that's incorrect that came from the
Red Cross
there was a Red Cross worker hearse who
saw an adobe house that was destroyed in
the earthquake in rubble and the
doorframe was still standing I said hey
that looks like it must be a good place
to be right which is true if you're in a
200 year old Adobe house yes any other
house it's no stronger than anywhere
else and it usually has a door in it
right and that door tends to be moving
around and hitting you during the
earthquake thank you Red Cross so what
you're saying is what you said is get
under any kind of table even if you know
I always think it has to be like a
steel-reinforced table you're saying it
could be the cheapest crappiest IKEA
table and I apologize to the good people
at IKEA I'm just using them as an
example it's a bad table is protecting
you from the things falling down yeah
all right so the building's probably
staying up what's probably coming down
are the lights unless they've been
hooked up right I mean maybe they house
them no not professionally we didn't I
was told that came out of my end of the
brachot so no
I just said those are just there with
gum most places you're far more likely
to be injured by things being thrown
around the room and the table helps and
we've also seen places with really very
like spindly little school desks holding
up concrete form we want to show this
picture this is from a 1985 Mexican
earthquake and look at that if people
this is just to illustrate that even
desks that aren't that strong are
protect would protect people and save
their lives that they got under them
those are concrete slabs it's holding up
an awful lot right yeah so yeah it's the
best place to be it doesn't feel the
emotional you know when the earthquake
happens and it's terrifying getting
outside is a deep emotional need but
that's the way people get injured so
fight that need I don't need get
underneath a desk or something like that
there was a something called the
triangle theory which blew up on the web
a couple of years ago and it said sort
of get near something like a chair or
something and and you're you're here to
tell us that theory is wrong don't
listen to the triangle theory don't
listen to the triangle of life they said
that they found a schoolroom of crushed
children under their desks in the Mexico
City earthquake you just saw what the
Mexico City really looks like
em'ly sides the earthquake was at seven
o'clock in the morning so there were no
children in school so it that's just an
internet rumor but unfortunately a lot
of people have taken that it's been
really serious it's it's it's a study in
viral communication yeah why did that
one get out oh there's one guy promoting
it and somehow everybody seemed to
believe it you also say it's very
important to keep sneakers underneath
your bed why well because broken glass
is the most obvious thing and yeah I
have a friend I actually started
emulating it take a pair of sneakers tie
it to your bedpost
put an extra pair of glasses if you need
them to find your way out which I would
and I'm extra pair of keys because I
probably not gonna be able to figure out
where my keys are at that point and just
leave that under my bed just in case
right the other problem we're gonna have
is water you say that a lot of people
have some extra water around the house
but it's not nearly enough water to take
care of them for as long those that are
going to need before water is brought
back is that right yes okay so it may
take up to six months to get water now
you can't store six months of water
but you can have enough to be able to
drink for a few days and then you know
FEMA is gonna probably be you know
bringing it into US but you want to go
stand in line to wait for your water or
would you rather have it at home so we
say however much water you've been
storing mine she took just get some more
so you've got a serious message here but
it does sound like it is actually quite
hopeful that you can survive an
earthquake you can it's actually
statistically highly unlikely that
someone's going to die in an earthquake
it's just do the smart things and
prepare for it well and the other piece
is we're gonna live through it but it's
probably can it could bankrupt you I
mean do you have earthquake insurance I
do yeah all right you are one of 10
percent of Californians yeah that hammer
but I have no other kind I don't have
car insurance or any I just got
insurance I don't qualify for Obamacare
I'm just all putting it all in the
earthquake
yeah yeah so okay so make sure you get
the earthquake insurance if you don't
have it yeah yeah if you don't mind
being bankrupt when you've lost your
house you see one last question you've
devoted your life to earthquakes you're
retiring now before the big one is and
this is a little bit of a sick question
is there some small part of you that's
disappointed that you did not hold this
position during the big one I wish I
could say it was a small part a bit part
yeah I spent my life studying this thing
I'd like to know if I was right yeah and
and I'm down to just hoping I live to
see it
[Laughter]
let's have read it let's agree to
disagree okay I know that I don't want
to get in the way of your personal
ambition and curiosity but I'm hoping we
don't live to see it Wow still friends
what this is
you